over the past 12 months this has become
a familiar scene for human rights groups
and activists in russia
this time the axe has fallen on an
organization made famous for identifying
the millions of victims of stalin's
purges
as the judge finished reading the order
to liquidate memorial shouts of shame
came from the public gallery
[Music]
it is
telling to us that russia is moving
from the authoritarian
indian system
to some kind of postmodern
totalitarian
system
in russia
which would be kind of a
linkage
with the soviet regime
and even partly to the starting region
so it's a very dangerous
development
more recently memorial has spoken out
against the repression of critics under
president vladimir putin
outside court as elsewhere there's
little room for that in today's russia
prosecutors accuse memorial of
organizing large-scale media campaigns
aimed at discrediting the russian
authorities
what happened today was very sad
although it would be untrue to say we
weren't ready for it it was one of the
unfortunately predictable outcomes of
the present judicial system of course
nothing is over with this we will appeal
and memorial will live on with the
people because it's the people behind it
serving this great cause first and
foremost the work will continue
the move against memorial caps a year
that has seen authorities jail or outlaw
individuals or groups that criticize
vladimir putin
but the ban against memorial
international stands out even in the
current climate and would have been
unthinkable just a few years ago
bernard smith al jazeera